so Ilan Musk who's the founder of Tesla
and also the founder of SpaceX he's done
a ton of stuff with artificial
intelligence and advanced computers and
all that fancy stuff uh he is warning us
about well let's listen to him directly
I think we should be very careful about
artificial intelligence if I would guess
at what our biggest existential threat
is it's probably that so we need to be
very careful with the artificial
intelligence increasing client to think
that there should be some regulatory
oversight at the internet bigger the
national and international level just to
make sure that we don't do something
very foolish I mean with artificial
intelligence we are summoning the demon
you know you know all those stories
where is the guy with the pentagram and
the holy water and he's like yeah you
sure you can control the demon then work
out I think there will be no hell 9,000
going up to Mars Hal 9000 would be easy
it's way more complex and I mean good
put in Hal 9000 a shame yeah okay that's
some seriously powerful stuff our
biggest existential threat is artificial
intelligence and it will be like quote
summoning the demon now this is from a
guy who is doing this stuff I mean he
really all his businesses are future
businesses he's leading the charge on
this stuff and he's warning us this
reminds me I feel like this is like a
scene in a movie where they throw back
you know after the war the terminators
have taken over and they're like
remember that guy who said that rain
there's a broken TV on the ground yeah
it's just avoiding a cook from this show
about us joking about it right right
right
I often on this show because I love
these types of stories and I often talk
talk about how I think that eventually
the robots are going to take over and
yes I've watched enough of the sci-fi
movies it's it's just in there it's just
a piece and that doesn't mean we stop
technology stop moving forward or all
this future stuff which is all really
cool but how do we heed a warning from
this guy he's the one that's doing it
right
he's the one that he knows about this
you know he's one of the Primo guys but
how do we how do we acknowledge that
it's happening while the technology just
keeps moving on what do we do I don't
know man Dave I'm not that smart but I'm
telling you right now watching this
video this man knows something hey I
don't he he needs to be brought back
into Beckerman Jared because I don't
know if he [ __ ] with some artificial
intelligent rat that he created in his
back room that stole from him yeah you
know on some micro level and he's like
oh [ __ ] so like the weighted the
gravitas in which he spoke that scares
me so that that's what yeah III was the
matter of fact this which with which he
said it because he's the one building
this the technology for this happen
Google's got you know Ray Kurzweil the
singularity and all that uh but he's one
of the ones doing it so because of that
he said it's so calculatingly like this
[ __ ] is going down so humans enjoy why
you got it cuz we got about 10 years
left and I think with the subject yeah
and even brought the movies that we see
is this all yeah that'll never happen
yeah but then again wasn't joking wasn't
smiling about it so again and then
they're recreating humans evidence for a
while and even ago I mean you have these
innovators then you have even people who
are more religious I grew up Christian
as well and so when you have it then
they think hey you know what you guys
got look up for what you're creating cuz
then they're gonna come back and get you
I mean whatever really want to bring it
back from my past is not me that's good
yeah so it seems like the creation of
this to do is to make a superbeing yeah
and that's what obviously I mean these
companies in these corporations these
innovators have said they want to do and
then what do we do with those what's the
point of it so control them well I've
created on yeah do we need to pay more
attention to science fiction because
science fiction usually is about 50
years ahead of what ends up happening
you know that that seems to me to be
like a rough arc that you get with this
stuff in all of these movies so you got
you know terminator what was the Will
Smith movie about uh I Robot I'd say I
am Legend but I'm sure with the Ebola
that's gonna happen to the Minority
Report there are working on spree crime
kinda stuff and yeah
in all this stuff so science it does
give us a little bit of a key right it
always goes to the bad place I suppose
maybe we need is there could they do a
science fiction movie that does it ever
work out innocent why does it never work
out why the Futurists it never works out
I feel like in in our reality in our
world I think that there are so many
checks and balances and technology can
move such an incremental pace that if
something really does prove to be
dangerous they'll shut it down like
drone like drones from Amazon right
that's that's just being it's being beta
tested it's being I don't feel like but
also they're gonna become smarter that
they'll shut us down I think that that's
the fear they feel like though are we
gonna wake up one day and really they'll
be an army of a hundred thousand drones
trying to kill us all like will that
just happen or maybe our houses have all
become so future eyes that they can
start [ __ ] with our I need a lock us
in and shut down our internet or even
there's maybe a small group you try to
go positive try hey I got ya I got first
level is before the robots take over
that's also crazy say there's people
zombies control yeah is like a people
control the robots we have our NSA
things where they can tap in and
activate things our phones and which we
thought we had control of yeah that's
already happening I mean and in people I
mean there's confused is about our cars
our computers now my Google Maps knows
that we're here right now totally right
and that you get you get you can undo
that but it can still be tapped in so
maybe is a fueling control your house in
your life in your car you don't know it
yeah I'm just totally fascinated by this
digital stuff you know I one of the
things there was that Stuxnet virus that
was screwing up the Iranian nuclear
stuff and basically through a computer
virus that they some whoever sent it
there they sent there they were able to
screw up actual physical real-world
things you know they through a computer
virus they then made you know things
spin too fast or and it actually caused
real explosions like so it's it's
happening right now and I guess we just
have to be aware of it you have one
final scary thought yeah you got nothing
scared oh yeah we shall see how it all
plays out
you